in the last hour Donald Trump has held
his first news conference since last
November's presidential election it was
dominated by a slanging match in which
he accused intelligence agencies of
releasing a dossier containing claims
that Russia has material which could
compromise the president-elect mr. Trump
also insisted he had no Russian business
ties and gave details of his plan to
hand over full control of his business
empire to his two sons while he's in the
White House and what I'm going to be
doing is my two sons who are right here
Don and Eric are going to be running the
company they are going to be running it
in a very professional manner they're
not going to discuss it with me again I
don't have to do this they're not going
to discuss it with me and with that I'm
going to bring up sherry Dylan and she's
going to go these papers are just some
of the many documents that I've signed
turning over complete and total control
to my son's Alexandra frame is a
business columnist at the Times and his
recently returned from Washington where
she was the papers us business editor so
alex is it going to be easier said than
done for Donald Trump to disentangle his
business ties and avoid these confidence
of interest it's going to be very
difficult I mean his two sons stone and
Eric they're no dummies that there's
their smart businessman they will do
their best Trump is going to appoint an
ethical advisor but it's going to be
very difficult to avoid the perception
of a conflict of interest if for example
he's you know president and Heather that
the Department of Justice has a conflict
with a foreign banks such as Deutsche
Bank it's just resolved that you know
Donald Trump owes three hundred million
dollars to Deutsche Bank there's going
to be a perception of a conflict of
interest even if he tries very hard to
stand bank and his businesses are still
going to be making something like a
hundred million dollars a year in profit
as well well they are but there's two
things we need to remember here one is
that there's nothing in law that
prevents the president from retaining
his business interests he's one of the
few elected officials allowed to hold on
to them the other is that a lot of
Americans aren't as bothered about this
as we are as the people on the Left
coastal people in New York City who
don't like Donald
Trump are and they regard themselves you
know the ordinary people who voted for
Donald Trump they're they're
pro-business they regard themselves as
you know temporarily impoverished
millionaires just waiting for their
chance and so I think they like that
he's a businessman so there could be a
case for saying he should sell its
assets but really a lot of American
voters will say no why should he I think
a lot of American voters you know
applaud it and they might actually see
it as a good thing and I guess there are
safeguards in the system anyway I mean
people will be scrutinizing his behavior
very closely to ensure that he behaves
properly I mean he doesn't have to
divest himself under law but he could be
impeached if he you know it's found
guilty of bribery or corruption and
every business deal that his sons do is
going to be very heavily scrutinized so
they'll have to be really careful though
the Democrats will be all over this and
he actually said that he's been turning
down business opportunities as well
since he became president as well I mean
his does that play well you mean I dunno
what to believe when he says things like
that I wouldn't be surprised if foreign
governments have been approaching him
but I'm not sure how much attention
people are really paying to that now we
heard separately today they're all these
various allegations thrown at him that
the Russians have somehow got a hold on
him because they have compromising
material he's been accused of colluding
with Russian intelligence during the
refereeing the election campaign isn't
actually much evidence of business ties
between Trump and the Russians there's
not very much direct evidence you know
maybe maybe he does have direct business
a business but we haven't done enough to
you know Time magazine The Washington
Post looked very closely at this and you
know they have concluded that you know
the problem as far as they see it is
that a lot of his very senior and close
advisors do have links with Russian
financial institutions or friends of
Russia and that they say could pose a
conflict of interest because these are
the people that are whispering and
Donald Trump's ear